Bienvenidos a esta Crónica económica del
fin de semana aquí en France 24 este fin
de semana Contamos con nuestra compañera
Daniela Blandón Daniela bienvenida
Gracias Rodrigo Bueno vamos a comenzar
hablando de monedas latinoamericanas y
de algunas de ellas que están entre las
más valorizadas del mundo por qué
exactamente Pues aunque no lo creamos
Rodrigo existe un índice llamado msci
pero para no hacerlo muy técnico
básicamente esto mide el comportamiento
de las monedas de la región ese índice
subió más del 8% entre enero y marzo de
este año marcando el mejor trimestre en
un año y entre las cinco monedas más
valorizadas de este año frente al Dólar
aparecen tres latinoamericanas México
Colombia y Brasil una de las claves de
este buen comportamiento es la
reapertura económica de China que es un
socio comercial crucial para estos
países como lo explica a continuación
Janeth Quiroz Ella es la subdirectora de
análisis económico del grupo financiero
monex de México de términos vemos que
las monedas latinoamericanas han
presentado un comportamiento bastante
positivo como lo mencionabas en lo que
va de 2023 y en buena medida tiene que
ver con Eh pues la expectativa que se
tiene de recuperación económica por
parte de China sabemos que este país fue
el último en abandonar una política
estricta en contra del covid
la fue abandonando poco a poco hacia
finales del año pasado pero bueno al
final decidió abandonarla por completo y
esto generó la expectativa de que ante
la apertura comercial y de todas las
actividades económicas pues entonces
ordena mayor demanda de commodities o
materias primas que pues mucho de esto
se producen justo en América Latina y no
solamente estos países Rodrigo chile no
se queda atrás o moneda también se ha
fortalecido este año frente al Dólar ya
que china es precisamente el principal
consumidor de cobre que es su producto
estrella con este comportamiento las
monedas latinoamericanas están superando
a sus pares de mercados emergentes en el
resto del mundo pues interesante e
interesante ver también que para estos
países hay un punto en común y es el
petróleo Y es que aunque Los Altos
precios causan inflación también son un
bálsamo para sus economías Claro que sí
porque el precio del barril de crudo ha
tenido alza significativa sobre todo
después de que el club de países
exportadores y sus aliados liderados por
Rusia esto es conocido como OPEP más
dijera sorpresivamente que va a recortar
más de lo previsto inicialmente su
producción esto a partir de mayo Pues el
precio del wti que es la referencia para
el petróleo del Golfo de México comenzó
el 2023 en poco menos de 77 dólares
vamos a verlo en el gráfico sin embargo
A mediados de marzo llegó a caer por
debajo de los 67 y con este anuncio de
la OPEP más se ha venido recuperando y
es que los analistas dicen que lo que
busca este grupo es mantenerlo sobre ese
nivel de 80 dólares y tiene cómo hacerlo
ya que abaste el 40% de las mantas
mundial ahora volviendo a los países
México Colombia y Brasil son
exportadores de petróleo Así que si
entran más dólares por este concepto su
moneda se fortalece con las
consecuencias que esto trae para la
gente como lo explica nuestra analista
invitada el hecho de que la moneda esté
fuerte Lo que implica es que Eh Pues a
las personas locales les cuesta menos
comprar un dólar si nos cuesta menos
comprar un dólar y esa es la moneda que
utilizamos para adquirir mercancías de
otros países todos estos bienes que
están comprando que son importados pues
eh su precio depende entre otras muchas
cosas costos de transporte en sí Cuánto
cuesta el bien en el país de origen Pero
además también tienen implícito en el
precio este este efecto cambiado bueno
Dani pero no necesariamente un dólar
barato es bueno para todos tiene
ganadores y perdedores como todo en la
economía y es que así como se benefician
los importadores y los gobiernos o
empresas que tienen sus deudas en
dólares Porque pueden pagar más rápido
también hay Quienes son les conviene un
dólar bajo por ejemplo el México los
receptores de remesas al tener igual una
moneda fuerte entonces a la sede del
intercambio de de estas remesas
recibidas pues se van a obtener una
menor cantidad de remesas en la moneda
local ya que como es más fuerte Entonces
pues por el mismo monto enviado en
dólares está recibiendo pues una menor
cantidad en la moneda local lo cual Pues
también podría reducir el poder
adquisitivo de algunas familias si es
que pues no se aumenta O sea la el monto
enviado de de remesas estamos hablando
de remesas de Rodrigo que son bastante
importantes y para hacerse una idea de
esto de lo que significan las remesas
para la economía por ejemplo en México
que es uno de los mayores receptores del
mundo unas 10 millones de familias de
recibir esta clase de aportes del
exterior la mayoría desde luego proviene
de los más de 38 millones de mexicanos
que viven en Estados Unidos y este
solamente en un ejemplo de tanto es una
cifra muy alta para un país que vive
además muy cerquita de Estados Unidos y
que sufre también el problema
depende desde luego Dani Muchas gracias
por este repaso económico a nuestros
espectadores les invitamos a que sigan
con nuestra programación
[Música]